more vaccinations no lockdowns is the
message from the uk's prime minister
along with the admission that this time
last year the rate of infections was
much lower in one way our position today
is actually more challenging we have
higher levels of daily cases thousands
more
but in many other crucial respects the
british people
all of us collectively and individually
are incomparably better placed to fight
the disease
over 50s will get booster vaccinations
school children between 12 and 15 can
now be vaccinated the government
believes this will be enough to bolster
an already successful vaccine program
that has greatly reduced the rate of
people dying from kovid
the number of people dead now stands at
134 000
while an image like the national
memorial wall should ensure no one
forgets the vast scale of losses to
covet in the uk
across the river thames the government
is projecting a new phrase
living with kovid it's the new normal
and that comes with lifting many
restrictive laws and dropping plans for
covid passports for major events and
nightclubs
showing full vaccination or recent
negative tests it's a huge mistake yeah
it's typical of them boys over there
doing a u-turn freedom is what we fight
for that's what we should have
while england is dropping the passport
plan scotland is imposing one and in
europe despite sometimes fierce
resistance countries such as france
germany and belgium are using passports
to good effect what we've seen
throughout this pandemic is that britain
england in particular stays as an
outlier for many months while other
countries get on and do the right thing
only in the end to relent and do that
same thing ourselves so it could well be
the vaccine passports are a broad
success in other countries and
eventually the uk government introduced
them to england as well the government
says a lockdown would be a last resort
but a plan b would mean covered
passports and other measures however
there's some unease about not using face
masks and other risks inside buildings i
certainly think that some venues are
riskier than others and we should i
think in some venues still be requiring
distancing
and i also think we should be investing
in much better ventilation systems and
the fact that more cautious countries in
europe have lower infection rates than
the uk doesn't convince some that death
rates won't start climbing again
andrew simmons al jazeera london